please welcome to the show our dear
friend danny pellegrino
and you've been published a lot of times
but
this is all you yeah i was a ghostwriter
before so this is my first collection of
stories so it was so creatively
fulfilling because as a ghostwriter you
write in someone else's voice so it was
so exciting to tell my stories and and i
wanted the book to feel like a warm hug
when you read it and so i hope people
laugh i hope they enjoy it i think we
all need to laugh so we can get them now
so there's tons of pop culture there's
nostalgia there's a couple more dramatic
moments too but what's your favorite pop
culture story
the stories always change my brain just
thinks in pop culture there was one
birthday story that i wrote about in the
book my boyfriend i've been together
forever and for i'm not a big birthday
person we like to go to the movies on my
birthday and a few years ago we went to
the movies and jonathan groff
he was with liam michelle both broadway
people and they were i i think they were
sitting in front of me and so in my head
the whole time we're watching the stars
when all i'm thinking is like my
boyfriend planned them to come sing
happy birthday to me afterwards so i'm
sitting in a stars where like practicing
my excited face for like when they get
up after the movie to sing happy
birthday
which was crazy and that's not what they
were there for
and i got mad at my boyfriend then when
i finally realized that like they
weren't there to sing to me i don't know
what happened in a star is born i've
obviously seen the original i need to
rewatch it but it was like you know you
build things up and birthdays make us
crazy i think yeah we build things up in
our heads we have such expectation and
so you know it's a little more detailed
in the book but i yeah i thought like
these broadway people were there to sing
heavy birthday which is insane and then
i got mad at my boyfriend for not doing
that yeah
it's they're not for hire jonathan
groff's not like you can't hide mingle
with fabulous people i think anything
might be possible in your world danny so
uh but did you forgive him no okay
i love it all right well it's design
week here and uh when our drew crew
design hero mikhail welch was here he
said the 90s are coming back in home
decor and danny since you practically
got a phd in pop culture nostalgia we
thought that we could dig into some
stories where design and just and
nostalgia meet are you in i'm so excited
okay great do it all right tammy you're
the first story okay so first up some
people invest in bitcoin other people
invest in britney spears that's a
currency i can get behind
the new york post reports a super fan
named zachary gordon abraham has spent
20 years building a brittany bunker in
his house we're talking wall-to-wall
brick collectibles i love that and it's
like now oh it gets better look at that
it's now can you believe that i'd say
undervalued at
137 000. wow
and that's not all zachary even met his
husband through their love of britney
spears who doesn't love britney spears i
love that he met his
partner
yeah i know
and i get it too like i'm a pop culture
collectible person so i have like mine
the nanny barbie at my house oh my god
the friend dresser wow i love you i have
a rosie o'donnell barbie remember she
had we need to get do you have a barbie
uh charlie
we have charlie's angels dolls yeah well
this guy wanted to stop collecting uh
britney stuff but he he bought one more
and you know what he said
oops i did it again i did it
all right
next we're gonna go to the shagadelic
70s insider reports a woman named
charlie leanna murphy was so inspired by
jane mansfield's pink shag look that she
created her own pink penthouse and look
at this it look it features pink glitter
doors and shag shag shag everywhere and
it's not just wall-to-wall it's floor to
ceiling too wow
i feel like i need a claritin just
looking exactly
ironically yeah well she said she has to
vacuum every single day to make sure the
air doesn't get too shaggy and dusty
yeah that's a lot of shag carpet yeah
it's funny my friend jamie nelson she's
a photographer she shoots all of our
flower beauty campaign she's amazing
this is her bathroom like that is not a
joke she is the coolest chick on the
planet and
i thought it was her house that we were
talking about for a minute i love when
people go for it yeah totally yeah like
i love that all-in factor
in fact um
staying uh and moving to the 1970s for a
minute the daily mail reports a young
guy in the uk longed for that perfect
cozy 70s feel of his grandparents house
so he totally transformed his living
space into a 1970s cocoon
he spent listen 3 000 i know that sounds
like a lot of money but he was able to
redo his entire house he bought
everything secondhand on ebay and
facebook and then created this total
time warp i think he did a fantastic job
for i love it like i have this fantasy
of doing like a
late 90s inspired like so i want to get
like the inflatable furniture and i
always had a dream of the one of having
one of those macbooks we never got like
do you know the colorful map
yeah i wanted one of those so bad nice
and like you talking the full box my
dream drew was to sit in front of that
computer watch charlie's angels on the
tv and sit on my inflatable furniture
like that's all i want is a night late
90s danny i think
[Music]